do you have a greatest song or greatest
lyric that you ever wrote
there are a lot of individual lines and
songs that are I think are lines that
I'm prep particularly proud of or happy
but pleased with you know comfortable
with no favorite riff none of that I
would say
of the songs that came from a mysterious
source
where you feel you know it's a bit of a
cliche you know as as Robbie Robertson
actually said to me oh yeah you're a
conduit
you know there is something
where you feel as if the music is coming
through you
you're a part of it but it's not
starting with you it's coming from
somewhere and it comes through you if I
think back of three big examples of that
that first one was The Sound of Silence
Bridge Over Troubled Water was like that
where I said wow what is it wow but the
one that I where I knew it was Graceland
so the song Graceland Paul just give me
one last answer you seem very wise
you've lived through everything you've
created great masterpieces is there a
God because I need to know I'm getting
older is this it for me am I going to
die and that's it or am I going
somewhere please answer it and uh in a
serious manner this is my feeling about
God
or creator
the planet that I'm living on
is so beautiful
and the universe is so awe-inspiring if
that is the work of a Creator I say
thanks so much I really really love your
work on the universe excellent work for
coming from me Paul Simon to you really
dig what you're doing
if it turns out that there's another
explanation for
creation I am still
unbelievably grateful for my existence I
still think it's amazing I don't feel
like oh I've been a fool I thought it
was uh I thought it was God but this is
another it doesn't matter to me I'm I'm
content with I'm very grateful it's an
awe-inspiring experience to be here and
alive and but it's so cool that's the
end of it we have this existence and
then we have to disappear well I had a
friend
he's personal
his name was uh Gaelic he was a rampage
she was he was a Tibetan llama
uh he said well look I come from a
different tradition from you so maybe
it's easier for me to think this way but
what I believe is there's this dark
phase lasts for about three weeks
and then you uh become reincarnated and
I said I don't really
I'm not inclined to believe that but the
fact that you believe it and I have so
much respect for your wisdom makes me
feel that that's certainly a possibility
well on this topic I'll leave our
audience with a lyric from Seven Psalms
I'm not ready
I'm just packing my gear
wait my hand's steady my mind is still
clear I feel the same way it's beautiful
lyric you're a beautiful man uh the
world thanks you